. So I've already outlined to you how Donald
Trump owes not 300 million dollars, not 420
million dollars, but likely Trump's total
debts are about one point one billion dollars
to various creditors.
And I've already outlined in the previous
segment how this makes Trump a national security
risk.
There's another piece to this.
And that additional element is that Donald
Trump's businesses are just failing right
now.
Donald Trump's entire resort business is collapsing
partially due to his own mishandling of Corona
virus.
And it actually goes even further.
Trump's own desperation to open the economy
could well be motivated by the desire to rehabilitate
his own businesses.
What's increasingly clear is that were it
not for Donald Trump's reality show host career
on The Apprentice.
He might be totally insolvent because his
resorts are true money pits.
Trump actually used a bunch of his apprentice
money to go and buy golf courses and resorts
around the world, and they're all doing terribly.
Of the 15 golf resorts that Trump bought as
of 2015, almost none are profitable.
Trump bought Doral.
It looks like Dorel, I guess.
He pronounces at Doral for 150 million.
It's lost 162 million since his resorts in
Scotland have lost 63 million.
That much bandied about.
Hotel in Washington, D.C., near the White
House has lost more than 55 million dollars
between 2008 and 2009.
The Trump Organization lost one point four
billion dollars, as his tax documents show,
and none of those numbers account for 2019
and 2020.
And what's going on with Corona virus?
And and by the way, Trump alienating half
the country through his presidency has not
helped his business.
Half the country now would not go to his resorts
on principle because he's a failed, moronic
president.
He's damaged his brand and his reputation
through his presidency and then incomes coronavirus.
And it's a disaster partially because Trump
himself was slow to deal with coronavirus.
Trump being slow to take coronavirus seriously
has hurt Trump's own businesses.
And this gets us to why Trump behaves the
way he behaves.
Why is Trump dragging his an entire presidential
entourage with Secret Service to his own resorts
week after week after week to funnel money
into his failing resorts?
Why is Trump desperate to open hotels and
the economy even when it's too early during
Corona virus because he needs his resorts
open because they are failing?
All of these stories connect golfing at his
own resorts all the time, demanding the economy
open desperation to win reelection no matter
what.
Hiding his taxes.
Through any means he can, allegedly laundering
money through the campaign.
And there is a grand narrative here, and it's
that Trump is failing financially, personally
may be at risk of personal bankruptcy.
And he's desperate to stave it off.
Now, one last thing.
The big takeaway from all of these financial
revelations this week should not be Trump
is a fake billionaire.
There are too many people focusing on that,
people on the left and the right.
The real takeaways here are systemic.
The system allowed a lunatic sycophant to
become president on the false notion of being
a successful businessman.
And the Electoral College helped him despite
losing the popular vote.
That's a systemic issue.
The system allows the super rich people who
are super rich, at least on paper like Trump,
to pay no taxes through various mechanisms,
including tax loss, carry forwards and asset
depreciation, which I went over with you yesterday.
The system allows a president to funnel money
into their own businesses with no repercussions.
Trump has said he'd be great for the middle
class and people should pay taxes.
And he's been terrible for the middle class
and he doesn't pay taxes.
So the story is not fake billionaire.
This story is all of these other things which
we should focus on 38 days from now after
the election.
But between now and then, the election
is the focus.